the Joe Rogan experience now do the
neighbors look at you weird because
you're that guy lives in the woods on TV
um not that I know about they didn't
mention it no yeah they know you tell
everybody what you do know they know
they just know they watch TV a lot
it's Fairbanks Alaska darklings nothing
to do right are they weirded out by you
see on TV and see you right there I
don't think so
no I mean just normal person yeah but
even if you're a normal person you're if
you're a normal person on television
you're not a normal person people get
weird and they mention it they mention a
we you're on TV no they did in the
beginning I mean I've been I was down TV
now for six years it's not like we
talked about it normally what a like the
people in your town like Fairbanks is a
real city it's about 40,000 people I
think it's a small city but it's as big
of a city as you got in northern Alaska
the only place bigger Anchorage and
that's an 8 8 hour drive away yeah and
how many people is Anchorage
that's good whew it's got to be what is
angry about 300,000 maybe 400,000 almost
somewhere in there I'd love like half
the people in Alaska live in Anchorage I
think really I've only been there once
spent a couple days there we did some
gigs me and my friend Ari Shaffir and
did some salmon fishing up there comedy
gigs yeah we did comedy up there oh cool
yeah we just had on a whim we said hey
let's book a gig where we can fish
during the day and then do stand-up at
night so we did that for a couple days
it was fun oh yeah but it's just the
people up there were really cool man
like a really
[Applause]